hallo mein name ist bond ich brauche gar
nicht sagen was wir spielen weil jetzt
schon im titel gelesen habe einem
akinator geht es darum dass wir diese
person flaschengeist whatever sie stellt
uns fragen und wir müssen diese fragen
beantworten und bedenkt uns vor eine
person aus wo wir denken dass der
akinator diese person erkennen könnte so
was wir als erstes versuchen ist der
akinator eventuell mich also mit
fiktiven charakter con crafter irgendwie
wir fragen ihn einfach mal bitte denken
sie an eine reale oder fiktive figuren
werde versuchen sie zu erraten spieler
info alter wieso denn meint besetzt
wieso soll ich mein alter angeben tage
nummer eins ist deine figur männlich ich
würd mal sagen ja erlebt seine figuren
deutschland ja ist eine figur durch
youtube als auch direkt als dritte frage
youtube mit eingebunden kommen ich würde
nicht sagen dass ich berühmt bin oder
geworden bin aber ich glaube der
definiert also deswegen sage ich mal ja
spielte die gruppe war
was ist los in dieser website ja spielt
sie ist deine figur magisch ich war mal
in harry potter
wünsch ich würde sagen ich weiß nicht
einfach weiß man die deiner figur
aussieht ja weiß man hat eine glatze
vielleicht bald ich muss unbedingt zum
friseur schaut euch das an die sind
einfach die gehen bis zur nasenspitze
unten viel zu kräftig sachen einfährt
deine figur auf der long motto mit nein
ist nicht gut
es gab ja schon die ein oder andere
szene in meinen videos wo ich so
halbnackt auf meinem sofa im hintergrund
gehabt habe aber ich würde mich nicht
als pornodarsteller beschreiben lebt
seine figuren youtuber haus hin spielt
die figur bei hero mit ja die stelle
figur thw nicht real sagt ich weiß es
nicht balkon crafter ist er so ein
fiktiver charakter und ich selber als
luca villarreal also ich gebe einfach
mal weiß ich nicht an meine figur ist
blond ja ist eine figur ein fabelwesen
ich auch keine ahnung ist deine figur
student ja wo da die figur der nähe von
stuttgart
ich sag mal nein ist deine figur teil
von einem trio nein macht eine figur
fakten videos nicht glaubt der akinator
will auch tadel hinaus aber ich mache ja
eigentlich auch fakten video ich sag
einfach mal nein weil ich die derzeit
nicht mache spielt deine figuren heroes
mit was ist denn hier los wir nutzen
eine figur ein atemschutzgerät kicker
was geht denn der hätte ich schon längst
erraten können als ob irgendeiner der
baywa re 2 dabei waren atemschutzgerät
benutzt stimmt die war dabei der
benutzer diese maske dann erst gar nicht
mehr so dumm du kleine kerlchen ist ganz
schön klug ich benutze kein
atemschutzgeräten hat eine figur etwas
mit nahrungsergänzungen zu tun nach
deiner figur etwas mit einem schwein zu
tun nein ich kenne figur marokkanischer
nein trinkt eine figurine coca cola hat
nein ich will die figur mag mit nein
also bild hat man besser wählen können
ja es ist kontrakte um
ich wurde 23.700 mal gespielt was gegen
bläue okay ich habe jetzt ein neues foto
eingereicht und zwar das foto was ich da
ausgewählt habe dass sie habe ich da
eingereicht ich glaube das passt viel
besser zudem lukas nik name luca das
aktuelle fotos richtig mein fotos jedoch
besser ich habe die geschäfte in
westeuropa abschicken
danke dem foto wird nach überprüfung
sichtbar sein dann hat luca endlich ein
gutes bild bei akinator wir werden jetzt
mal etwas mega schwieriges machen und
zwar was ist denn hier schwierig west
idee die ukulele
mal schauen ob der akinator dass du auch
immer hilfe eilen muss ukulele die
machen das ist mal zusammen mit der
ukulele das heißt ich will jetzt
zusammen mit der kommen 90 mal hier
neben michael sitzen einfach gesungen
bisschen mehr best friend ist eine figur
weiblich
ich sage mal nein kommt eine figur aus
österreich oder deutschland wo kommst du
her ukulele und mir nicht so an
mein gott freunde ich habe einfach viel
zu wenig hobbys in meinem leben
coli
ob di luca gesehen
ich habe ihn schon los ich hoffe ich
will ja nicht wie lange dieser zeit
gedauert hat das ist mit doppelseitigem
klebeband und mehreren papier lagen hier
übereinander gemacht aller freunde das
ist auch hier ein youtube next level
schild aber jemand von euch ein spieler
von uns machen und überall auf twitter
posten luca und sein einziger wir machen
weiter also kollege kommt deine
geschwister reich oder deutschland du
keine ahnung trägt eine figur einen bart
ist endlich wieder ein tier nein spielt
deine figur in einer kinderserie nein
hat eine figur ein handy hast du ein
handy hat er nicht gerade als das stimmt
wir sehen uns in zehn minuten wieder
wir haben ein neues level erreicht meine
figur hat haare aber sie wird die
ukulele nicht erkennen denn die kann
in der tat alter will ich habe es
richtig kommen wenig hatte die nur noch
so in der iss auch scheißegal wie kommen
wir jetzt einfach weiter ich sehe schon
lokal im schnitt denkt ich gerade hey
luca im schnitt du denkst dir gerade
junge wie lange nimmt er schon oft nimmt
schon 36 minuten auf
ich lasse ich jetzt in ruhe jetzt
schneidest du bitte nicht mehr so viel
weil ich möchte nicht zum burnout crash
hallo hier ist der lokal im schnitt
danke für deine netten worte lukan der
vergangenheit wir sehen uns dann
irgendwann wieder ich möchte dass auch
luca meine figur hat keine haare sie hat
keine arme sie hat nichts mit sex zu tun
sie kann sich nicht bewegen sie hatten
nichts mit nahrung zu tun
sie ist kleiner als ein meta sie hat
nicht an der wm teilgenommen sie hat
nicht schon feuer zu tun
eigentlich gebe ich hier kein geld meine
figur keine rose haare ließen nicht
manchmal ordinär dies wahrscheinlich
nicht hat er nicht gehört was mit
elektrizität zu tun
nein die hat nichts mit der schule zu
tun sie ist kein nationalspieler sie ist
schweigsam sie hat mehrere klone der
etwas mit spielen zu tun schachfigur
juli
es soll das mit dem pizza dicke decken
sie trägt keine brille
ja sie wohnen bei mir die hat etwas mit
technologie zu tun
ja sie hat eine orange farbe nein es war
kein mit libero berlin die es ja die
sein spielzeug wie trägt nicht immer
spaß
sie mag nicht computer
sie spielt nicht mehr regeln wie mit sie
wurden im ausland sie macht keine videos
und versendet keine mail sie mal das ist
mir viel zu langweilig man wollt ihr
noch ein video mit mir und ukulele und
dem akinator und dann beschäftige ich
mich eine halbe stunde damit ihnen hier
tipps zu machen weil es doch gehört nur
bewertung